Sometimes the symptoms don't show up
right away.
Um,
and there's a kind of natural healing
that can go on just by leaving a war
zone.
And sometimes it's not good to talk to
people we think now right afterwards,
but rather to almost let the wound heal
a little bit on its own.
Um,
but some of the symptoms were aware of
and you know,
uh,
and they will be,
um,
a hypervigilance being in a sense,
hyper sensory mode.
So walking the perimeter are listening
with a cuteness the way you would in a
battle area.
Um,
or it might also be flashbacks.
inability to sleep or just one moment,
one of my soldiers to rob kiss low,
just found himself in a bar with his
arms around someone's neck.
He strangled this guy.
Um,
and then he,
and then he realized that he had heard
something and thought he was in fighter
mode and it just slipped into fighter
mode imperceptibly.
Um,
and that was about a year,
you know,
after battle he was in,
he was,
uh,
a long term patient at Walter Reed and
being treated by the way for physical
injuries,
um,
loss of arm use,
titanium armor placement in a and a leg
replacement.
Um,
other times it could also just be this
numbing that you,
you've,
you've had to,
um,
you're exposed to the sorts of stresses
that are so superhuman that you have to
protect yourself by numbing and you,
you continued to dissociate afterwards.
So those are some of the physical,
you know,
the physiological effects that we're
familiar with.
But what I'm trying to explore,
um,
are the,
the spectrum that doesn't necessarily,
um,
in,
in what may include some of these,
but also includes these con conflict
feelings,
get sexual feelings of feeling some
guilt for what you did or what you saw
and did your best,
but couldn't help to do even better than
you wished you could have done to
survive about all.
Um,
when your buddies does don't to be part
of an accident where yours no fault at
all,
no culpability,
but you,
um,
but,
but you were implicated,
causally implicated,
and you hold yourself really accountable
or to love your buddies more than you
love your spouse or your family.
And you know,
one of my soldiers said to me,
you know,
I'm in a tent with someone day in and
day out and I know,
and he passes wind at night.
I know that Fart,
you know,
and he said,
how can I tell my mother that I am?
Was that,
um,
physically close to someone so that the
feeling of betrayal almost of your home
family,
because you reattached to others who've
got you through it,
are also feeling that life has darren
boring at home when you've been so
wrapped up in revved,
revved up and hepped up,
that it's hard to want to,
hard to find the same kind of thrill and
adventure even though it's filled with
danger.